this program is brought to you by Emory
University
now prevention works but people are
skeptical of it and the skepticism is a
big problem and let me just postulate
and why everybody is so skeptical I used
to work in STDs and when I was in STDs I
was sort of occasion alee a clinical
researcher and I would see patients and
all I would see is the prevention
failures so everybody got an STD would
come to see me and a lot of them had
STDs before and at the end of a long day
you sort of walk out of the office and
you say you can't prevent this thing
it's just awful these people just won't
change their behavior and of course it
was hard for me to appreciate that the
people who change their behavior weren't
coming to see me so clinical
investigators by nature and people who
do research with people who are infected
are seeing the people who became
infected they're not seeing people who
don't become infected and a lot of
people are very skeptical about
behavioral science and things for those
reasons the other reason a lot of us are
skeptical is it's even difficult for us
to talk about sex and drugs and
homosexuality because even if it's not
difficult for us it's involving the
important intimate details of people's
lives when they feel like they're being
accused of betraying someone else or
have being betrayed themselves so even
if you don't feel uncomfortable with it
when you start to talk to people about
it it becomes quite uncomfortable
because it's uncomfortable to them so
it's easier to just say won't work
anyway why do we want to do it now the
other thing is that prevention isn't
perfect everybody doesn't change their
behavior and some people do I might
remind us that those of us who are older
that it used to be that forty percent of
American smoked and now twenty two
percent of Americans smoke that means
there's a whole lot of people who quit
smoking and didn't start smoking and
that whole lot of people is going to
save hundreds of thousands of lives
every year the future
but I'm still skeptical you can't get
people to stop smoking and you can't
start can't stop people from smoking
because I live in today but our
prevention efforts are really for
tomorrow and to stop the epidemic from
growing and stop the people in 2020 from
having to come to the pot center to get
their care the preceding program is
copyrighted by Emory University